nos preguntan las siguientes funciones
son pares impares o ninguna pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta antes de que lo resolvamos juntos
muy bien vamos a recordar las
definiciones para funciones pares e
impares una forma de pensar en esto es
qué pasa cuando tomamos efe de menos x
si efe de menos x es igual a la función
f x
entonces tenemos una función par si
evaluamos
efe de menos x y en lugar de tener la
función tenemos el negativo de la
función entonces tenemos una función
impar y sin ninguna de las anteriores se
cumple entonces es ninguna veamos esta
primera opción
fx es igual a 5 entre 3 - x a la cuarta
y la mejor forma que tengo para resolver
esto es evaluar a que será igual
efe - x esto es igual a 5 entre 3 - y en
donde veamos una x la reemplazamos con
una menos x menos x a la cuarta a que es
igual menos x a la cuarta potencia si
multiplicamos un negativo por un
negativo por un negativo cuantas veces
llevo bueno si elevamos un negativo a la
cuarta potencia vamos a tener un
positivo así que esto va a ser igual a 5
entre 3 - x a la cuarta que de nuevo es
igual a efe x así que en esta primera
opción
efe de menos x es igual a fx por lo que
es parc hagamos otro ejemplo este es gx
por lo que vamos a evaluarlo como g de
menos x y xi en cualquier momento se
sienten inspirados por el primer ejemplo
pueden pausar el vídeo y tratar de
resolverlo por su cuenta
gm x es igual a 1 entre menos x más raíz
cúbica de menos x
veamos si hay forma de simplificar lo
podemos reescribir esto como menos 1
entre x y podemos ver raíz cúbica de
menos x como menos 1 por x por lo que
podemos factorizar o sacar el menos uno
fuera del radical a que es igual la raíz
cúbica de menos 1
es igual a menos 1 por lo que es menos 1
por la raíz cúbica o el negativo de la
raíz cúbica de equis y ahora podemos
factorizar el negativo por lo que esto
es el negativo de 1 entre x + raíz
cúbica de x que es igual al negativo de
gx por lo que ésta es impar pues efe - x
es igual a menos
fx o en este caso gx gm menos x es igual
a menos gx hagamos la tercera aquí
tenemos hdx y vamos a evaluar hd - x hd
menos x es igual a 2 a la menos x más 2
a la menos menos x que es igual a x
positiva esto es igual a la hd x es
igual a hdx sólo se intercambiaron estos
términos por lo que esto es claramente
para y por último pero no menos
importante evaluamos jd x como jd menos
x que es igual a menos x entre 1 - menos
x
es igual a menos x / 1x y veamos no hay
una forma clara de factorizar el
negativo o hacer algo interesante en
donde pueda factorizar para tener jd x o
jd menos x por lo que esta es ninguna y
terminamos